[Music]
what can joe biden get done without the
senate
uh as i've mentioned a dozen times this
week
control of the senate is not yet
determined there are two
runoff senate races in georgia which
will happen on january 5th we'll be
covering them
very extensively if democrats get both
it will be 50 50 making kamala harris as
vice president
the tie-breaking vote democrats could
effectively control the senate but the
question is
without the senate what can get done
let's go through it first of all
there's a long list of executive orders
a lot of the disasters donald trump got
us into with executive orders
he can get us out of anything trump did
unilaterally
joe biden can undo unilaterally and
we've already talked about getting back
into paris climate getting back into the
who
getting rid of the military trans ban
reinstating
the dreamer program doing a lot with
kovid
and he's already launched a task force
there's tons of agency stuff you know
trump has reoriented the epa
to be weak joe biden could reorient the
epa to be stronger to protect the
environment
nasa was directed to stop studying
climate joe biden can get nasa to be
studying climate again
uh so there is quite a bit that joe
biden can do
foreign policy biden can do a lot of a
lot of foreign policy
things that aren't budgetary and thus
need to go through the house and senate
um but there's a lot of foreign policy
fixing relationships
fixing a bunch of the trade stuff with
china if china is willing
maybe getting us back into the iran
nuclear deal a lot of that can be done
without controlling the senate
the stuff that will be difficult is you
know infrastructure including green
infrastructure you need the house and
senate uh
tax reform real health care
reform you're going to need the house
and senate for that
unless you make deals with the devil
essentially unless you make compromises
that
i can't imagine joe biden would want to
do and that would be sort of my one area
of of caution which is
it's great for joe biden to talk about i
will be the president whether you voted
for me or not
i will be the president of the united
states not just of blue states
rather than red states it's great that
joe biden is saying that it's great that
joe biden
is you know a guy who has been able to
work across the aisle
these people are disgusting though these
republicans and the idea that you're
going to get
your agenda done with their help is
ridiculous
you you could maybe get pyrrhic
victories the idea of a pyrrhic victory
is
you win but you do so much
self-inflicted damage in winning that
you end up wondering is that really a
win
anymore and the way that would work out
as a pyrrhic victory would be
you get something done on paper but the
compromises you make
damage the country in such a way that it
ends up being awash for example
i think that's the risk of joe biden i
think there would be a
naivete if joe biden really thinks he's
going to work with these clowns
my hope is and i don't pretend to know
we'll see and if it doesn't go this way
we'll criticize biden
my hope is that biden is using language
of uniting
the american people but he is not
naively thinking
he's going to get a lot of this big
stuff done by working with republicans
because
they're just not going to work with him
in any way that would approximate what
we would call
a leftward move it remains to be seen
i'm not putting the cart before the
horse i will criticize
it if it happens but i am going to hope
and lobby that joe biden accurately
understands
that these are not people that you can
negotiate with uh
or or that you can bargain with because
you will just damage yourself
that's my sense right now i'd love to
hear your thoughts
we have a great bonus show today you can
get instant access
by using the coupon code fresh start
when you sign up at joinpakman.com